right on three o'clock like to welcome
everybody to today's
infrastructure services meeting 7th of
june
i'm going to start with
zoom attendees we have councillor clark
councillor abbott and councillor soper
apologies we have his worship the mayor
and councillor kit moved
moved second moved and seconded
i'll put that motion all those in favor
yes
that is
carried
there's no public forum
it takes us on to the first item which
is receiving the minutes of the
infrastructure services meeting
third may
can i have someone move that remove that
chair thank you councillor and second it
was coot i'll put the motion all those
in favor all right
against that is carrick that takes us to
the amendment of the reserves omnibus
management plan um
welcome karen
good afternoon
um so in front of you you've got the
proposal to amend the rule reserves
omnibus management plan to reclassify
tisbury reserve
this proposal was consulted on as
a part of the annual plan process we did
receive submissions on it which were
predominantly um in favor for this to
happen
and this was for us to future-proof the
use of the land
we're asking for you to receive these
submissions and also
to make a recommendation asking that you
make a recommendation to council to
change the classification from
recreation reserve to local purpose
museum reserve
to enable collections storage facility
development
okay um
right what i'm going to do is i'm going
to move that we
received the report can i have someone
move that please
thank you council amanson seconded let's
cook put the motion all those in favor
all right against that is carried right
i'm going to open it up for questions
uh of carolyn do you have any questions
no uh yes council ludlow no questions
may i comment you can uh comments and
questions thanks
um
i guess we're we're fortunate and and
that what's been uh proposed was well
signaled through the consultation
process and so we've had the opportunity
to get feedback from it
as carolyn says there's no
major obstacles put up there are people
who ask questions as we did
around the distance from the museum and
i think we satisfied ourselves with the
answers that we were given and the the
transport time to and from and the
benefits that come from
um
being risk adverse and having a storage
facility away from the potential of
inundation
i'm quite comfortable with um
ratifying what's been proposed and i'm
happy to move uh
recommendations two through to five
okay i'm just gonna ask for a second to
okay
see you thank you okay
i'm still open to discussion i see
there's two hands up councillor
clark
first
yeah caroline three chair caroline um so
if this is approved today is that the
end of the process does the
reclassification
take effect or does it need to go
further through to the minister's office
we do need to get this um clarified by
the minister of conservation because it
is a change in status of the reserve
land yes
and secondly uh what sort of time frames
do you think that's likely to take
i'm just going to check with my learned
colleague behind me
it could be a couple of months
okay thank you
councillor sopa
thanks that was actually my question mr
chair so it's been answered
okay yes
so
if the minister should not be willing
what
is plan b
so this proposal is for reclassification
of tisbue reserve um tisbue reserve
would stay as a recreation reserve
and uh so from a parks and recreation
perspective we don't have a plan b at
the moment so if you're looking at
museum storage that's another question
evelyn
kelso
sorry loudly
it could be clark
um
i guess the chance of that happening is
is very slim because you're changing one
reserve classification to another
if it was completely being removed as
any formal reserve i think maybe there
would be ministerial questions but i
doubt that
because the process is done at our end
and as a formality it needs to be
ratified by the minister i'm
highly confident that there won't be any
change
okay i have a question regarding the
lease
now um
how does this work obviously uh released
back to council from
the museum or
is there a chance of the whole museum
storage facility
becoming a cco because of its
you know when you read through this it
opens the door for a
quite a good business case and i'm just
wondering
um what
how was the lease worked out
so the lease has worked like any lease
on reserve land
throughout from parks and recreation
it's just a standard lease documentation
right
right and and there is an exchange of
yeah
and the cost of that how has it worked
out um we haven't worked out that far
right counselor yeah
you know it's just interesting if if um
wouldn't make any difference if the
entity
leasing the land was a a cco rather than
a council
just a standard within council
department
yeah
i'm sorry i can't answer that question
through this paper we were just looking
at the reclassification of london we
haven't worked through going to the
leasing of the londos yet this is just
reclassification okay council hello i
think the question really for the chief
executive i think it would still be
classified as a cco would it not
um
mr chair the answer to that is that the
trust board now in place with a
museum-centric approach will still be a
cco
um as caroline has said that's not part
of this report and the reference to
lessees in this report is in relation to
the current lessees not any future one
okay
all right that's fine
right no more questions or comments uh
it's been moved and seconded i'm going
to put those recommendations
all those in favor
all right
against
that is
councillor clark's trying to trick sorry
councillor clark before i
close it off did you have another
comment thank you chad yeah i do have a
question for caroline again um
in a previous meeting a few months ago
unless cook raised
some issues about
the whole
storage facility and the time frames
around that and moving of the collection
into it once it was built and she i
think using her work she said it was
fairly ambitious
and the following meeting you gave us an
assurance that the classification of the
reserve would be done in time for the
annual plan to be presented which is
this month so we've got a two month
delay now with having to go to the
minister
does that mean that the
um
original commitment we have for the
storage facility to be built
and for this
collection to be moved into which
preempts any work on the museum itself
is that now pushed out
now
council o'clock the time frames um of
the reclassification of reserve have
held so we're still keeping with the
same
time frame that we originally were going
with so there isn't any change to that
well hang on i just i just asked you
before caroline through your chair
um
whether there was any more steps the
annual plans adopted this month
um and so you're saying that we haven't
got the reserve changed for another two
months at the minister's discretion um
we've just got uh steve on
line here with his hand up we can't see
you steve but i
yes we can
uh kiara thank you mr chairlock um i
might get a better answer this one in
terms of the program
we're actually ahead of schedule um
councillor clark
uh we had anticipated through the
original planning that this would all be
dealt with by october this year
but we
through using the annual plan process
we've been able to speed that um time
frame up by two to three months so
actually we're still well on track from
a program point of view
through you chair just any uh
question now for steve
um i wasn't asking about speeding up the
program and there was no mention of
october at the last meeting when i asked
caroline that the specific question
about when the reserve was was likely to
be reclassified and she said
and i quote in time for the annual plan
to be adopted well that's this month
so we're pushing back two months on that
is that pushing back the whole program
too much
no it is not thank you that's fine
okay we've had that answer right we were
at the stage of we had the
eyes and i'm gonna continue
with the nays and there were no nays so
that motion that
recommendations are carried
thank you
right
that now moves us on to the city city
streets closed
circuit
television project
and we've got michael to speak to that
thank you through yourself chair
um i'm going to take the report as read
um it is a fairly straightforward report
in relation to we are
presenting this report and seeking two
councillors to
move on to that group and would seek
this this committee to propose that
recommendation through the council
okay so the first thing is to receive
the report that's moved councillor
abbott can i have a secondary thank you
miss cute i'll put that all those in
favor all right
that is carried right so what we're
gonna
what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna ask for
uh volunteers for this committee can i
we're after two
so councillor skelt we have his name
councillor
lewis
uh
council clark do you wish to put your
name forward uh actually i wish to put
your name forward chair
i think with your uh technological
background you'd be an ideal candidate
for this
um look look thank you for that but um i
actually see myself as chair
um is um
really more of an accountability role in
that the this committee uh the cctv
committee will report back to this
committee and
and that's where i see my
my role yeah thank you though
mr t i'll put my name forward okay
counselor as well
i was just saying chair that i put my
name up to fill the void if someone has
got a key absolutely keen desire
for it to go on rather than me i don't
mind but i wouldn't quite like to be on
anyway
okay so i will give you the choice
council lewis we have councillor skelt
and councillor sopa
um
they if would you let would you be okay
with those two
it doesn't need to go to a vote or
someone that really desires it right
that's fine okay well that saves the
voting then if you
withdraw
okay well that
there's no other
so the second motion chair is that we
confirm um
councillor skelton soper as the council
appointees yes that's moved councillor
crackit seconded council ludlow
so that uh councillor skelt and
councillor sopa are appointed
to this committee as council reps and
they join
um
nine other people
but we one thing that hasn't been
confirmed is that
the prior meeting
uh there was talk of ewi aniwi
um was it a warden or something it
wasn't listed
on that last meeting yeah i suggested a
maori warning yeah correct right so do
would you wish to add that as well
this is the opportunity to add
i think a person then i would do it in
the mean or is you happy
if we
just watch it
no i was omitted in the first one
is the chair of the maori wardens
is it going to be you no it'll be our
team leader mandy ritty okay council
clark
just two items that came out of the last
meeting chair
one was the scope of the project and is
that something that we need to give our
councillors delegate councillors a bit
of a steer on there was a bit of a gulf
between
where we were heading when we were
discussing with the police which was
i guess to safeguard the cbd
um south city cbd for one of better
words and windsor
and where they were off uh seeking
further input than that which was to
have arterial roads coming into the city
that would have
enhanced uh capacity around
number plate um recognition and the
likes and i just wondered whether that's
something that we need to give our two
councils a bit of a steel now or with
that something that will come back to us
because that scope significantly widens
it out
yeah
through soft chair um that would come
back in relation to next steps relation
to cctv
and and the other issue was the issue of
not reinventing the wheel because this
is quite a technical area
and there was some discussion the last
meeting about sometimes how effectively
these work and who would monitor and i
just wonder whether we have some good
practice examples in some other cities
that have recently upgraded that we
could tap into as well
mr chair if i could just say to the
committee
the next steps refer to an investment
logic mapping exercise and i am reminded
that
one of the committees of council i'm not
sure whether it's this one or a risk
that has been advised that
after undergoing those sorts of projects
there's a much tighter sense of
what it is that you're really looking
for and the benefits that will be gained
from that so i think i would be
confident in saying to you if you let
that process run then you will be able
to consider the outputs from that
with far more knowledge and advice
just as a final comment chair three of
you
part of the discussion with the police
was also about who would pay
and there was some again some gulf
between
whether the city would pay for arterial
roads with
number plate recognition which is more
dealing with the incoming crime or
criminals or whether the police
themselves would would have some input
into the cost of the project so it
wouldn't solely land in the city
through self-care just in response to
that um i'm gonna draw back that should
be part of the investment logic map
again um
coming back
uh that should spell out where the
funding
aspects will come from as well and what
will be
requested of council in relation to that
yeah thank you chair
okay i guess as uh chair of this
committee my question would be when
would we expect our
any feedback or and what form would the
first feedback be a report on on
progress
uh through yourself chair um
i at this meeting i would struggle to
give you the advice of timeline in
relation to that as i would need to wait
until their first committee meeting so
they can set their timelines to come
back to the committee and council so uh
be able to report back as soon as
they've had their first meeting
okay
right
okay i guess we we are underway now and
i guess i can be happy that uh
that that progress
is all go
okay so the
recommendation
uh will be that uh
we've got councillor rickman councillor
skelt
and councillor soper as the two
councillors
on the cctv committee and that the place
be offered to the murray wardens group
on the on the project
for the on the project work group so
that's been do we move that
yeah i moved to the second
recommendation there and i believe it
was
one second
yep okay so i'm going to put that motion
although some favor all right
against that is carried thank you
now we have um the city's submission
to the
mfe
on recycling systems
and that who was speaking to that
is that uh steve or is that
it's steve
yeah thank you um through your chair um
look this is just uh following on from
an earlier workshop just uh receiving
the submission that staff have made on
behalf of city council to mfe
and
um just noting that uh your counselors
pottinger and clark
approved that submission
or had a view of the submission prior to
us sending it off
right any uh questions or comments
cancel that line
just as a comment to um commend those
who've been involved in putting this
together i think it reflects uh some of
the concerns that were expressed
when the subject was raised
it is
simply a submission and uh
i'm comfortable with how councils being
represented
councillor clark
thank you chair uh just one thing i
think that's actually missing with
hindsight is that
because this is really giving a bit of
advice to uh to the ministry
is that we've um not reflected that one
our
recycling contract at the moment is is
about to open a
plastic palletizing plant
unless i've missed it somewhere yeah i
believe i saw it in the
report where it was referred to um the
fact that we had both village and
palletizing
here in southland
okay
thank you
okay
any other questions or comments
right we've got two recommendations that
we receive
the report and uh notes that submission
has been approved by
two learned people
uh in order to meet the submission
deadline of 22nd of may 2022
removed seconded
i'll put that motion all those in favor
all right yes that is carried
it takes us to
the activities report where we have some
quite technical roading um
matters michael
thank you councillor hand over to my
colleague to start
in relation to the
leisure and wreck component um richard
richard
kiara just uh update on the pool
nothing too unusual to report there has
been a dip in april in terms of visitor
numbers which is typical for an april
but exacerbated this year because of uh
uh covered impacts and uh reacquainting
community to the pool other than that um
some good progress on the cafe in terms
of its um
performance compared to previous years
there's some good progress to be made
there
thank you
any questions on the pool
all right
thank you through yourself chair just in
relation to some of the infrastructure
areas there is a little bit around uh
the roading side
might draw your attention to um gala
street the under the cuban channel
aspect we've got a bit in there around
um doing the renewals in relation to
gala street which will change um the
giveaway in relation to
macalester and gala
in relation to that curb and channel
renewal
the
reason behind that is that is one of the
priority bus routes and that will allow
that
better flow of transport through that
area in relation to our priority bus
route
council adelaide
thank you chair um
the planned change at
gala and mcmaster street is uh
is a good move and follows
as a potential resolution to some
concerns that have been expressed by
residents in mcmaster street with the
speed of some vehicles traveling down
there as the road begins to become quite
narrow i guess with the fact that
those people will have to stop at gala
street that'll be one traffic calming
measure that we can look at and gauge
the effect of before
we go to the extremes that perhaps some
of the residents were looking to to call
for so thanks also to our
writing staff who who
helped deal with that inquiry so i'm
happy to support this
right any other comments or questions on
the activity
report
or a comment mr chair just um in terms
of
the progress that's made on
the streetscape it's actually quite
noticeable the difference now seemed
like for a long time
nothing much was happening but i just
walked down esque street today and
part of its east street is actually
concreted and the rain gardens are being
formed and all those sorts of things i
need to adventure down don street to see
the same but pleased to see the photos
in here and
positive progress
don street's even further ahead yes i
think once you start seeing the tiling
on top of that concrete there is
thailand oh yeah yeah absolutely yeah
yeah um councillor clark
thank you just on the issue of the stead
street stop bank
i notice there's a comment in there
about
the installation of cultural artwork and
the shared use of a path from the
airport family so just a question for
steve um
it would be helpful to know what that
cultural artwork actually means
and is it on the whole stead street um
structure or is it just from the airport
down and the other issue is is that
something we should do now
or if a new council had a mind to
find a use for the stead street wharf
would be better to tie that
cultural artwork in with some
development there
yeah
thank you
through you mr chair i thank you
councillor clark
um so part of the package of the
cultural narrative is actually wrapped
up in the the wider project for stead
street so it's a funding requirement
that's overseen by kanoa which is the
regional development unit of mb
um and so we do have some pre-existing
commitments for this cultural narrative
in terms of its location it's primarily
focused on the stop being
itself
and so it's designed to tell the story
of the water and the relationship
between the stop bank so there is um
quite a separation from the bridge so it
roughly starts about airport ave
and works down towards um uttatata
so
uh it is a commitment we've got already
and that's um i guess the team have been
working really hard with the waihulpai
roonaka
to
pull that first design
component together so hopefully that
answers your questions
just just one issue with that steve um
we get to see the design and have some
idea of the cost or is the cost
solely part of the
money we got from central government and
if it is then
i guess i see you're nodding but i guess
there's there's two issues um
if it's funded by the project itself
do you feel we have a bit of due
diligence to make sure that we're
getting better for money for that um or
do we just assume that the project funds
what the project funds and as long as it
doesn't sit in the house office then
we'll be okay with it
uh yeah councillor clark this is a uh
this is a i guess it's tied into the
funding commitment with kanoa and so
we have to deliver on this um in terms
of the advice we've got at the moment
is we are tracking well from a budget
point of view uh the partnership that we
have had with the roonaka has been
really positive
um
and we're certainly committed to an
outcome there we can certainly look to
bring
a concept of the design back to council
at a later date once that has been
firmed up
and just one final thing steve um
this project is centrally given governed
by shovel ready but we are a partner and
then aren't we
are we contributing funds to them
yes um so kanoa
of the 15.5 million dollars in the
project
um we've received 10.8 million dollars
from kanoa for this
and so council has contributed the
remainder of that
so that that begs the question then if
we
and my final question if
the last step is to do the the cultural
landscape artwork which i'm really in
favor of
um
whatever cost has attached that will be
a cost to council not to the project
uh it it should be spread between the
two but it might be that might be advice
i need to go away and come back with the
exact confirmation of how the budget's
been split on this
plus the other works still yet to be
completed so it would be helpful to know
whether that artwork is beyond the 10.8
that would be helpful to know that yeah
i can follow that up for you thank you
councillor abbott i saw your hand up
there before
uh yes thank you um councillor clark's
questioning and the comprehensive reply
from steve answer my question
okay council lewis
thank you chief i hate to be a
would put a thistle into this but the
cultural artwork or any artwork
in a comparatively narrow road or which
it's got an increased speed limit
um
have we actually discussed that with the
transport department make sure it's not
a distraction
from the drivers down there and
particularly visitors that have come
true to a city who may not be familiar
with it and might be glancing sideways
whilst they were driving
uh yeah through you mr chair i thank you
councillor lewis in terms of that
um the cultural narrative and the
artwork is largely focused around the
shared pathway
um and i guess our es environment
engineering services team sorry have
been working through that with thirunaka
[Music]
again i'm happy to bring that design
back to the council once we've got
something firmed up with turinaka
we don't believe that there will be a
problem yes i wasn't too sure but uh
concerned about the renaissance i'm sure
that they have their expertise but i was
more concerned about the transport
department
yeah no at this stage i think we're
we're comfortable it's largely focused
in and around this shared pathway
and it is off the roadway itself lovely
thank you very much
uh steve i have a question it's
regarding airport avenue now
um it's not it's not the most beautiful
airport avenue when you're arriving into
the city um but it has a lot of
potential
to become something something quite
amazing with
you know tree-lined avenue
but is what is the master plan
beyond
um making it uh more friendly for
walking cycling is there a master plan
to actually make it something with um
selected trees down either side
that when you're either driving or
coming from the airport
you know it's quite quite spectacular
rather than the sort of
um i'm not sure my my looking
um
you know roadside stuff we have
yeah um three chair um
we are working on the design at the
moment we have uh received some tenders
back for the actual works um we're just
finalizing
the costs and that engagement uh again
i'll be happy to bring something back to
the council in terms of what that design
looks like
[Music]
we are mindful of
the overall budget cost and we are
keeping within that and i think that's
the track we are hitting in terms of
budget at the moment
and a design has been developed built
around creating that shared pathway
it is largely leaving
the existing plantings as much as we can
intact
um that's about as much of the design as
i've seen i'll need to come back with
more advice on that
no that's okay i've just had quite a few
comments about that you know that that
vista when you're arriving and
it potentially could be so much more but
now that's another subject so
thanks for that
um
right
the recommendations are that we received
the report
can i have someone move that please
counselor skelt seconded councillor
lewis i'm gonna put that motion all
those in favor
against that is carried right that is
the end of
this agenda in public uh kind of someone
moved that we're going to public
exclusion please
um move to miss cook second in
councillor skill and i put the motion
all those in favor
against
thank you